أعتقد أن القضايا التي
نعمل عليها هنا في نهاية المطاف تعرف أشياء
مثل منع التدخل
والانتخابات من البلدان الأخرى
وإيجاد التوازن بين منح الناس
صوتًا والحفاظ على سلامة الناس ، فهذه
ليست قضايا يمكن لأي شركة
معالجتها ولكن اسمح لي  أعطيك مثالاً
عن مكان أعتقد أن
الحوكمة المستقلة فيه مفيدة حقًا ، لذا فإن
أحد الأشياء التي سنبدأ في
طرحها قريبًا هو السماح
للأشخاص في المجتمع بالحصول على
استئناف مستقل عندما يشعرون
أن محتواهم قد تمت إزالته
بطريقة لا تتلاءم مع
معايير مجتمعنا ، حسنًا ، فأنت
تعلم الآن أنك تنشر شيئًا إذا أبلغ شخص آخر
عن ذلك ، فقد نزيله إذا
وجدنا أنه كلام يحض على الكراهية أو
ينتهك سياساتنا ولكن إذا كنت
لا توافق  ستكون قادرًا على
الاستئناف وستكون أيضًا قادرًا على مناشدة
هيئة مستقلة وهذا مثال
تعلم فيه أن الهيئة المستقلة
ستكون لديك  الآن أسنان
وسلطة وستكون شفافة في
القرار الذي يتخذهون ، وإذا كنت
أرغب في نقض ذلك الجسم المستقل
الذي لن أكون قادرًا على ذلك
حتى لا تتنحى عن منصب رئيس مجلس الإدارة ، فهذه
ليست الخطة ، فهذه ليست الخطة  ستغير الخطة
أي شيء أقصده في
النهاية بمرور الوقت ، أعني
أنني لن أفعل ذلك
إلى الأبد ،
لكنني بالتأكيد لا أفكر حاليًا في
أن هذا منطقي